Narrator:
TONIGHT, A SPECIAL EPISODE
FEATURING BUSINESSES
STARTED IN COLLEGE...
O'Leary: DON'T WORRY --
WHEN YOU GET OLDER,
YOU'LL TURN INTO
A CAPITALIST.
WOW.
WE BOTH WENT ON
TO COLOMBIA GRADUATE SCHOOL.
ATTAGIRL. I LOVE YOU.
WE STARTED THE BUSINESS
FROM OUR COLLEGE APARTMENT.
Greiner: WOW.
IMPRESSIVE.
I WON $1.3 MILLION
IN SCHOLARSHIPS.
I'M SUPER IMPRESSED.
Narrator: ...AND THE MOST
EXPLOSIVE SHARK FIGHT EVER.
YOU GUYS JUST DON'T LIKE
WHEN YOU GET SCOOPED.
LORI, THAT IS SUCH CRAP.
NO, IT IS NOT CRAP.
I'M TELLING YOU --
I'M NOT SITTING HERE --
RUN OUT THERE
AND CHANGE IT TO $100,000.
EXCUSE ME. I'M TALKING.
YOU'RE REALLY
PISSING ME OFF RIGHT NOW.
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
I'M GONNA SAY
SOMETHING RUDE TO YOU.
[ LAUGHS ] NO, DON'T BECAUSE
YOU'RE NOT A RUDE GUY.
AND I DON'T WANT TO SAY
SOMETHING RUDE TO YOU,
SO I'M JUST GONNA GO.
THERE WAS NO NEED
TO DO SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
LET'S GO.
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
DAYMOND JOHN DOMINATED
THE FASHION WORLD WITH FUBU.
NOW HE'S THE BRANDING EXPERT
BEHIND MULTIPLE GLOBAL BRANDS
GENERATING BILLIONS IN SALES.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
RENOWNED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
FIRST INTO THE TANK
IS A UNIQUE WAY TO ILLUMINATE
IN AN EMERGENCY.
HI, SHARKS. I'M ANNA STORK.
AND I'M ANDREA SHRESHTA.
AND OUR COMPANY
IS LuminAID.
WE'RE SEEKING $200,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 10%
OF OUR BUSINESS.
LuminAID BRINGS LIGHT
TO THE WORLD.
OUR FIRST PRODUCT
IS AN INNOVATIVE SOLAR LIGHT
THAT IS NOT YOUR TYPICAL
FLASHLIGHT OR LANTERN.
IT STARTS OUT LIKE THIS --
A SLEEK, LITTLE PACKAGE,
AND IT INFLATES
TO DIFFUSE THE LIGHT
AND CREATE A LIGHTWEIGHT,
WATERPROOF LANTERN.
LuminAID'S L.E.D. LIGHTS PROVIDE
UP TO 16 HOURS OF ILLUMINATION,
AND IT HAS
TWO BRIGHTNESS SETTINGS.
YOU DON'T NEED ANY AA's, C's,
OR D's -- JUST SUNLIGHT.
USING THE BUILT-IN
SOLAR PANEL,
YOU CHARGE IT IN THE SUN
DURING THE DAYTIME,
AND THIS ENERGY IS STORED
IN A THIN, EFFICIENT,
RECHARGEABLE BATTERY.
LuminAID IS PERFECT
FOR OUTDOOR ADVENTURES.
TAKE IT CAMPING, HIKING,
AND EVEN BOATING
BECAUSE IT'S COMPLETELY
WATERPROOF, AND IT FLOATS.
THIS PRODUCT IS USEFUL
IN A VARIETY OF SITUATIONS,
AND WE'VE PROVEN
THAT THERE'S GLOBAL DEMAND.
BUT WHAT WE'RE
REALLY PASSIONATE ABOUT
IS THE "AID"
IN "LuminAID."
OUR LIGHT
SHINED BRIGHTEST
FOR THOSE
WHO ARE LEFT DEVASTATED
AFTER A NATURAL DISASTER.
WE HAVE THE PERFECT TOOL
FOR FIRST RESPONDERS TO USE
ON THE GROUND
IN AREAS WITHOUT ELECTRICITY
OR THAT ARE RAVAGED
BY FLOODS.
AND BEFORE DISASTER
EVEN STRIKES,
LuminAID IS PERFECT IN THE HOME
AND CAR, JUST IN CASE.
WE'RE COMMITTED TO MAKING
LuminAID A WORLDWIDE BRAND
AND HOPEFULLY
MAKING PEOPLE'S LIVES
A LITTLE BRIGHTER, TOO.
WE ALWAYS SAY,
WHEN LIFE GIVES YOU LUMENS...
Both: ...GET LuminAID.
WHO WANTS TO JOIN US?
[ CHUCKLES ]
THAT WAS GREAT.
Cuban: OH, LORD.
EXPLAIN THE TECHNOLOGY.
IT'S REALLY SIMPLE.
IT'S A SOLAR PANEL,
A RECHARGEABLE BATTERY
REALLY SIMILAR
TO THE RECHARGEABLE BATTERY
THAT'S
IN YOUR CELLPHONE.
THANK YOU.
JUST A BRIGHT L.E.D. LIGHT.
SO, IT INFLATES TO DIFFUSE
THE LIGHT LIKE A LANTERN,
HAVING
A LAMPSHADE EFFECT.
DID YOU CREATE THIS?
YEAH. SO, WE'RE
ACTUALLY STUDENTS.
WE WERE AT COLUMBIA
GRADUATE SCHOOL OF ARCHITECTURE
RIGHT AFTER
THE HAITI EARTHQUAKE IN 2010,
PEOPLE WERE COMPLETELY
WITHOUT ELECTRICITY,
AND THERE WASN'T
A LIGHTING PRODUCT
THAT WAS BEING DISTRIBUTED
IN VOLUME.
SO WE SPENT THE SEMESTER
PROTOTYPING THE PRODUCT BY HAND.
Shreshta: WE MADE THE FIRST
50 OF THESE IN OUR KITCHENS.
AND AS IT HAPPENS,
A YEAR LATER,
WE OURSELVES WERE IN JAPAN
DURING THE 2011 EARTHQUAKE.
AND EVEN FOR US,
OUR PROTOTYPES --
I MEAN, WE USED THEM
DURING THE POWER OUTAGES THEN.
AND WE REALIZED, LIKE,
THIS IS A PRODUCT THAT HAS --
YOU KNOW,
FILLS A UNIVERSAL NEED.
HOW LONG DOES IT LAST?
IT LASTS 16 HOURS
ON THE LOW SETTING
AND 10 HOURS
ON THE HIGH SETTING,
AND THEN YOU JUST RECHARGE IT
IN THE SUN IN SEVEN HOURS.
[ BLOWS ]
DO YOU HAVE
AN ENGINEERING BACKGROUND?
I DO. SO,
I STUDIED ENGINEERING
AT DARTMOUTH COLLEGE
IN MY UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE,
AND THEN WE BOTH WENT ON
TO COLUMBIA GRADUATE SCHOOL.
TELL --
TELL US ABOUT SALES, THEN.
IN THE FIRST YEAR,
WE DID $250,000 IN SALES.
WHOA!
IN THIS LAST 12 MONTHS,
WE DID JUST OVER $1 MILLION.
Greiner: WOW.
Herjavec: IMPRESSIVE.
WHOA!
[ CHUCKLES ]
SO, WE ACTUALLY HAVE --
I MEAN, THERE ARE
THREE SORT OF CUSTOMER TYPES
THAT WE SELL TO -- IT'D BE
INDIVIDUALS DIRECTLY ONLINE,
AND THEN WE HAVE, YOU KNOW,
WHOLESALE/RETAIL/COMMERCIAL,
AND THAT INCLUDES
OUR INTERNATIONAL DISTRIBUTION,
AND THEN THE LAST WOULD BE
NGOs AND GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
TELL ME THE MARGIN.
HOW ARE YOU SELLING THE NGOs?
HOW ARE YOU SELLING THEM?
WHAT PROCESS ARE YOU USING?
SO, WE HAVE A COUPLE
LARGER NGO CUSTOMERS.
OUR LARGEST IS
IN INTERNATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS
THAT PROCURE SUPPLIES
AND DISTRIBUTES THEM
IN EMERGENCY SITUATIONS.
LIKE A RED CROSS OR...
EXACTLY.
SO, IT'S ACTUALLY ShelterBox.
YOU CAN SHIP 50 OF THESE
FOR THE SPACE OF 8 FLASHLIGHTS.
SO, THEY HAVE PURCHASED 30,000
UNITS IN THE PAST 10 MONTHS.
THEY'RE ONE OF
OUR LARGEST CUSTOMERS.
AND TELL ME
WHAT YOU SELL IT TO THEM FOR.
WE SELL TO THEM FOR $8.75.
AND HOW DO YOU SELL --
WHAT DO YOU SELL IT FOR
IN THE OTHER TWO AREAS?
OUR DIRECT-CUSTOMER PRICE
IS $19.95.
AND WHAT'S YOUR COST?
COST TO MANUFACTURE IT
IS $4.75.
AND DO YOU HAVE
SOME KIND OF FUNDING BEHIND YOU?
WE EACH PUT IN $7,500
OF OUR OWN MONEY
BECAUSE WE THOUGHT
WE HAD A GOOD IDEA.
SO, THEN
WE LAUNCHED THE PRODUCT
THROUGH A SUCCESSFUL
CROWDFUNDING CAMPAIGN.
WE RAISED $50,000
ON A GOAL OF $10,000.
WE'VE LEVERAGED
BUSINESS-PLAN COMPETITIONS
AND GRANT COMPETITIONS, AND
WE WON AN ADDITIONAL $195,000.
[ LAUGHS ]
AND WE'VE PUT $145,000 OF THAT
BACK INTO THE BUSINESS.
BRAVO.
IT'S BRILLIANTLY DESIGNED.
[ Chuckling ]
I'M SUPER IMPRESSED BY YOU.
DID YOU PATENT THIS?
WE HAVE
TWO UTILITY PATENTS FILED.
OUR PATENTS WERE FILED
THROUGH COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY,
WHERE WE WERE STUDENTS
AT THE TIME, SO...
MM.
OH. DO THEY OWN
A PIECE OF YOUR COMPANY?
THEY OWN 2%.
SO, I MEAN, WE WERE STUDENTS,
AND WE HAD NO MONEY...
NO MONEY.
[ Chuckling ] ...TO --
TO FRONT THE PATENT.
IT ALL WENT INTO THIS.
SO, YOU -- YOU PAY THE -- HOW DO
YOU PAY THEM FOR THEIR 2%?
SO, OKAY, SO,
THEY ALSO HAVE 2% ROYALTIES
FOR ANY
COMMERCIAL RETAIL SALES.
ROYALTIES, YOU SAY?
John: AH.
YES. RIGHT UP
YOUR ALLEY, SO...
HOWEVER -- HOWEVER,
ALL OF OUR NGO, MILITARY,
AND HUMANITARIAN-AID SALES
ARE EXEMPT FROM THAT.
I LIKE THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE
A ROYALTY DEAL IN PLACE
BECAUSE I'M GONNA
TACK ONTO THAT.
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU $200,000
AND ATTACH
TO THE COLUMBIA ROYALTY.
WHENEVER THEY GET PAID,
I ALSO GET A ROYALTY OF 4%,
ALL RIGHT?
MY ROYALTY GOES AWAY
AFTER I'VE RECEIVED BACK
FOUR TIMES ON MY MONEY,
ALL RIGHT?
I GET NO EQUITY.
ONCE I RECOVER $800,000,
POOF -- I DISAPPEAR.
POOF.
DO THAT AGAIN.
[ LAUGHS ]
YOU -- YOU EXPERIENCE THE
WONDERFULNESS OF MR. WONDERFUL,
BUT THEN HE'S GONE
LIKE THE DREAM HE WAS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WELL, THAT'S A --
DEFINITELY AN INTERESTING OFFER.
OF COURSE IT IS.
WELL, I MEAN, YOU KNOW,
IT'S NICE TO THINK ABOUT
YOU GOING AWAY AFTER A TIME,
BUT WE'RE ACTUALLY HERE...
[ LAUGHTER ]
I FEEL LIKE THAT
EVERY DAY.
NO.
WE ALSO WANT
A STRATEGIC PARTNER.
SO, YOU WANT TO SELL EQUITY.
YOU WANT TO SELL EQUITY.
YEAH, WE THINK
THE TIME IS RIGHT.
WE WANT A PARTNER.
Herjavec: FOR SURE.
YOU KNOW, WE WANT TO BUILD
THE INFRASTRUCTURE AROUND IT.
SO, LADIES, HERE'S MY CONCEPT.
HAT'S OFF. YOU'RE BRILLIANT.
I WANT TO GIVE YOU $300,000
FOR 20%.
MY MAIN GOAL IS TO LICENSE IT.
I WANT YOU TO BE INVENTORS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR OFFER.
I MEAN, I THINK THAT IS
A LITTLE BIT MORE EQUITY
THAN WE WERE HOPING FOR,
BUT IT'S A --
BUT YOU WON'T
HAVE TO RAISE AGAIN.
AH...EQUITY --
IT'S SO EXPENSIVE.
[ Chuckling ]
IT IS EXPENSIVE.
WE KNOW.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE...
YES, SELL YOUR SOUL
AND YOUR FUTURE.
YOU KNOW, THIS PRODUCT
CAN CHANGE THE WORLD.
I LOVE PRODUCTS
THAT ACTUALLY HELP
MAKE THE WORLD A BETTER PLACE
AND HELP PEOPLE
THAT ARE IN HARD SITUATIONS.
SO, MY OFFER IS $200,000
FOR 20%.
I JUST
BELIEVE IN YOU GUYS.
I THINK THAT YOU'RE AMAZING
AND BRILLIANT
[ CHUCKLES ] BUT SHE'S TAKING
MORE EQUITY.
I KNOW I AM ASKING --
I'M MAKING A STIFFER DEAL HERE,
BUT I THINK
THAT IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE
A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF MY TIME
IN WORKING WITH YOU
AND HELPING YOU FOR --
YOU DID IMPRESS ME, LORI,
BY ACTUALLY BEING GREEDIER
THAN KEVIN ON THAT ONE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WELL, THAT'S MY OFFER.
I LIKE MY DEAL A LOT,
BY THE WAY.
I LIKE YOU.
I BELIEVE IN YOU.
I THINK IT'S LOOKING BETTER
AND BETTER BY THE MINUTE.
WELL, WE'RE TAKING ALL THINGS
INTO CONSIDERATION.
LORI, THANK YOU.
THAT BEING SAID, YOU KNOW,
THAT IS A LITTLE STEEP
IN TERMS OF THE VALUATION
OF THE COMPANY THAT WE WERE --
ATTAGIRL. I LOVE YOU.
OH, MY GOD. I LOVE THESE GIRLS.
[ STORK LAUGHS ]
I LOVE THESE GIRLS.
SO, IF THERE'S ANY WAY
YOU COULD COME DOWN
IN YOUR EQUITY TO MAYBE --
IT'S THE GREED PROBLEM,
ISN'T IT?
THAT'S WHAT BRINGS YOU BACK
TO TEAM WONDERFUL.
[ LAUGHS ]
THIS KIND OF SAVAGERY --
30%, 20%.
[ LAUGHS ]
WE KNOW WE'RE GONNA NEED
MORE MONEY...
OF COURSE YOU ARE.
...SO, RIGHT OFF THE BAT,
TAKING MORE CASH OUT
OF EVERY UNIT JUST DOESN'T --
YOU MAY NOT NEED MORE MONEY
IF YOU LICENSE.
YOU'RE GONNA NEED
A LOT OF CAPITAL.
MY DEAL --
THEY DON'T NEED MORE CAPITAL.
THEY CAN BE DESIGNERS,
AND THEY CAN BE CREATORS.
THEY DO.
WITH YOUR DEAL,
THEY HAVE TO START SHIPPING.
THEY HAVE TO HANDLE TO HANDLE
BEING A SALESPERSON...
DO YOU WANT TO DO DAYMOND'S DEAL
OR NOT? YES OR NO?
Narrator: ANDREA AND ANNA
HAVE THREE OFFERS ON THE TABLE
FOR THEIR SOLAR-POWER LIGHT,
LuminAID.
LORI'S OFFER IS $200,000
FOR 20%.
DAYMOND'S IS $300,000 FOR 20%.
KEVIN'S IS $200,000
FOR A ROYALTY OF 4%
THAT EXPIRES ONCE HE RECEIVES
A RETURN OF $800,000.
John: MY DEAL --
THEY DON'T NEED MORE CAPITAL.
THEY CAN BE DESIGNERS,
AND THEY CAN BE CREATORS.
O'Leary: THEY DO.
WITH YOUR DEAL,
THEY HAVE TO START SHIPPING.
THEY HAVE TO HANDLE TO HANDLE
BEING A SALESPERSON...
DO YOU WANT TO DO DAYMOND'S DEAL
OR NOT? YES OR NO?
Cuban: WAIT. HOLD --
HOLD ON. HOLD ON.
HOW BIG CAN YOU MAKE
THE INFLATABLES?
BECAUSE IF YOU CAN
MAKE THEM BIG,
THAT CREATES A WHOLE NEW
CATEGORY THAT CHANGES THE GAME.
Shreshta: YEAH, I MEAN,
THAT'S THE IDEA BEHIND OUR --
YOU KNOW, THE COMBINATION
OF THE SOLAR L.E.D.
AND THE INFLATABLE,
SO YOU HAVE TO OPEN YOURSELF UP
TO EVEN, LIKE, NEW SHAPES,
APPLICATIONS,
AND INTEGRATIONS,
LIKE LIFE VESTS
OR RAFT-TYPE INTEGRATION.
I MEAN, I LIKE IT.
OBVIOUSLY, IT'S A GREAT PRODUCT.
I'M MORE INTERESTED
IN WHERE YOU'RE GOING TO GO.
YEAH.
AND I'M SURE
YOU'RE NOT DOING THIS
JUST TO BUILD THIS,
RIGHT?
NO, WE'RE NOT.
SO I'M GONNA
MAKE YOU AN OFFER,
AND I'M GONNA SHOW KEVIN
WHAT CREATIVITY'S ALL ABOUT.
HE TRIES.
SO, I'M GONNA OFFER YOU
200K FOR 15%,
AND I WANT THE OPTION
TO LEAD THROUGH YOUR NEXT ROUND
OF FINANCING
IN THE AMOUNT OF $300,000.
I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT YOU GOT
A FOUNDATION TO GROW FROM,
'CAUSE, AGAIN,
WHERE YOU'RE GOING
IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN WHERE YOU ARE.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S EXACTLY THE AMOUNT
I WAS GONNA OFFER.
MY OFFER IS $200,000
FOR THE 15%.
YES, YOU WILL NEED
MORE MONEY.
I-I DO SEE
A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT PATH.
I'M NOT SURE YOU'RE 100%
CRYSTAL CLEAR ON THE FUTURE.
EXACTLY, AND I LOVE THAT.
I SEE A RETAIL MARKET.
I DO SEE THE NGO MARKET
CONTINUING TO GROW.
UM...AND THEN YOU CREATE
THE NEXT ROUND.
LADIES, YOU HAVE FIVE OFFERS
ON THE TABLE.
THAT'S RATHER RARE
IN THE SHARK TANK.
NOW YOU HAVE TO
MAKE A DECISION.
THANK YOU TO ALL OF YOU.
YES.
WOULD IT BE OKAY
IF WE STEPPED OUT?
I WOULD NOT LEAVE THE TANK
AT THIS JUNCTURE.
OKAY, THANK YOU
FOR THE ADVICE.
BAD THINGS CAN HAPPEN.
WE WON'T, BUT OKAY.
[ LAUGHS ]
SO, ONE THING
WE DIDN'T THINK ABOUT
COMING IN HERE AS MUCH
WAS THE FUTURE AND, YOU KNOW,
SOMEBODY REALLY BEING THERE
TO HELP US FUND THAT.
WE APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S OFFERS.
MARK, I THINK
YOU GOT A DEAL.
THANK YOU. I'M EXCITED
TO WORK WITH YOU GUYS.
WHAT WAS IT?
YOU GUYS ARE AWESOME.
I'M SO CONFUSED.
I DON'T KNOW.
OH, IT'S GONNA BE GREAT.
Stork:
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
Cuban:
YOU GUYS ARE AMAZING.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
I'M EXCITED.
THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR TIME.
Greiner:
REALLY SMART, LADIES.
GREAT GIRLS.
GREAT LADIES.
AHH!
HIGH FIVE. [ LAUGHS ]
SMART GIRLS. I'M GONNA --
I'M GONNA GO APPLY FOR A JOB.
WE WON'T HIRE YOU.
[ CHUCKLES ]
YOU DON'T KNOW THE FUTURE.
SOMETHING COULD SURPASS THIS
IN TWO SECONDS.
RIGHT. WELL, THAT'S THE RISK
OF INVESTING.
YEP, THAT IS.
I THINK WE MADE
THE RIGHT CHOICE.
I MEAN, WE REALLY COULDN'T
GO WRONG.
THEY'RE ALL
GREAT PARTNERS.
EXACTLY.
BUT MARK
REALLY SAW THE VISION
FOR THE COMPANY
AND THE TECHNOLOGY,
AND THAT WAS REALLY IMPORTANT
TO US, BECAUSE WE DO, TOO.
Narrator: EARLIER THIS SEASON,
NAVY S.E.A.L. ELI CRANE
AND HIS WIFE, JEN,
MADE A DEAL WITH KEVIN AND MARK
FOR THEIR UNIQUE BOTTLE-OPENER
COMPANY, BOTTLE BREACHER.
YOU GUYS ARE AWESOME!
LET'S DO IT!!
[ LAUGHTER ]
LET'S SEE
WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW.
THINGS HAVE BEEN REALLY CRAZY
SINCE "SHARK TANK" AIRED.
OUR WEBSITE CRASHED.
IT WAS TOTAL CHAOS.
WITHIN THE FIRST WEEK,
WE PROBABLY HAD
60,000 BOTTLE BREACHERS SOLD.
NOW WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT,
"OKAY, HOW DO WE
MAKE ALL OF THESE?"
WHERE ARE WE AT
FOR THE DAY?
RIGHT NOW, WE'RE AT 975,
SO WE'RE DOING PRETTY GOOD.
AWESOME.
WE WENT FROM
MAKING 175 A DAY
TO HAVING TO MAKE
OVER 1,000 A DAY.
WE HAD TO MOVE INTO
THIS NEW FACILITY.
WE WENT FROM
8 EMPLOYEES TO 32,
AND WE'VE ALSO BEEN ABLE TO HIRE
A LOT OF VETERANS,
SO WE'RE PRETTY PROUD
OF THAT.
Jen:
WHEN WE PITCHED, WE WERE AT
A HALF MILLION DOLLARS IN SALES.
NOW, IN THREE MONTHS,
WE'RE AT $2.5 MILLION.
ELI, JEN.
HEY. HOW YOU DOING?
O'Leary: I WANTED TO COME HERE
AND THANK JEN AND ELI
FOR THE TREMENDOUS SUCCESS
THEY'VE HAD
SINCE THEY AIRED
ON "SHARK TANK."
YOU ARE AT $2.5 MILLION --
THAT'S GREAT NEWS,
BUT I'VE ALSO HEARD ABOUT
THE BACKORDERS.
BOTTLE BREACHER
IS A CLASSIC SUCCESS STORY,
WITH THE PROBLEM
SUCCESS BRINGS.
WHENEVER THERE'S A HUGE SURGE
IN THE INTEREST IN A PRODUCT
AND YOU GET
A WHOLE BUNCH OF ORDERS,
YOU'VE GOT TO FULFILL THEM.
OTHERWISE, YOU END UP
WITH A LOT OF UNHAPPY CUSTOMERS.
WE'VE GOT TO MAKE SURE
THIS GETS FIXED.
ALL RIGHT, NOW I KNOW
WHAT THE CHALLENGE IS.
Jen:
YOU'RE GONNA GROW AND BE TALL?
YEAH.
NO, YOU'RE GONNA STAY
MY BABY.
[ ELI LAUGHS ]
I JUST GOT OUT OF THE NAVY
A COUPLE MONTHS AGO.
JEN AND I WERE
REALLY CONCERNED WITH,
"HOW ARE WE
GONNA PAY OUR BILLS?
BECAUSE OF
THE "SHARK TANK,"
WE'VE ACTUALLY BEEN ABLE
TO PROVIDE FOR OURSELVES
AND A LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE
IN THE AREA.
EVEN THOUGH
I DON'T WEAR A UNIFORM ANYMORE,
I STILL FEEL LIKE
I GET TO SERVE THIS COUNTRY,
AND "SHARK TANK" HAS GIVEN US
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT.
All: BREACHER UP!
Narrator:
NEXT UP IS A YOUNG COUPLE
WITH A MISSION TO HELP
A GLOBAL COMMUNITY.
HI, SHARKS. I'M JACK.
AND I'M ALLEY.
AND WE'RE THE CO-FOUNDERS
OF TAALUMA TOTES.
WE'RE HERE SEEKING $110,000
FOR 15% OF OUR COMPANY.
IT'S TIME TO KICK
THOSE BORING, GENERIC BACKPACKS
TO THE CURB.
ALLEY AND I
WENT TO UGANDA
DURING A SUMMER BREAK
FROM COLLEGE,
AND WE COULDN'T
TAKE OUR EYES OFF
ALL THE CRAZY FABRICS THERE.
SO, WE PICKED OUT A FABRIC
AT THE LOCAL MARKET
AND FOUND A SEAMSTRESS
TO SEW ALLEY A BEAUTIFUL SKIRT.
AND JACK
GOT A LITTLE JEALOUS,
'CAUSE HE COULDN'T
PULL OFF A SKIRT,
SO HE CAME UP
WITH ANOTHER IDEA.
HE HANDED THE SEAMSTRESS
HIS BORING, GENERIC,
SOLID-BLACK BACKPACK
AND ASKED HER TO MAKE
A MORE EXCITING ONE
OUT OF THE LOCAL FABRIC.
AND JUST LIKE THAT,
THE TAALUMA TOTE WAS BORN.
SO, TAALUMA TOTES ARE BACKPACKS
PAIRED WITH COUNTRIES.
EACH ONE IS MADE OF TRADITIONAL
FABRIC FROM THAT COUNTRY
AND THEN FUNDS A MICROLOAN
FOR A PERSON IN THAT COUNTRY.
SO, WHEN YOU CARRY TAALUMA,
YOU CARRY A COUNTRY.
SO, WE STARTED THE BUSINESS
FROM OUR COLLEGE APARTMENT.
AND WITH GRADUATION
AROUND THE CORNER
AND TAALUMA'S MOMENTUM
REALLY BUILDING,
WE TRADED OUR CALCULATORS IN
FOR TOTES
AND MADE THIS
NIGHTS-AND-WEEKENDS PROJECT
OUR FULL-TIME JOBS.
SO, SHARKS,
THE QUESTION IS...
Both:
...WHICH COUNTRY WILL YOU CARRY?
[ CHUCKLES ]
WE'D LIKE TO PASS OUT
SOME SAMPLES, AS WELL,
IF THAT'S ALL RIGHT.
YEAH.
JACK, WHERE'D
YOU GO TO SCHOOL?
WE BOTH WENT
TO VIRGINIA TECH.
WE STUDIED
ENGINEERING THERE.
ALLEY,
WHAT COUNTRY IS THIS?
THAT ONE'S
AN INDONESIA TOTE.
Greiner:
WHAT COUNTRY IS THIS?
MALI.
MALI?
THAT'S RIGHT.
BEAUTIFUL.
AND A BEAUT --
THIS IS MR. WONDERFUL.
WE KNOW YOU LIKE GREEN, SO WE
PICKED YOU THE GREEN INDIA TOTE.
THANK YOU.
John: THANK YOU.
DAYMOND,
THAT'S THE GHANA TOTE,
AND, MARK,
THE IVORY COAST.
SO, EACH OF THESE BACKPACKS
HAVE A STORY.
THIS ONE FUNDED A MICROLOAN
FOR AN ARTIST IN INDONESIA
TO BUY MORE CRAFTS
AND SUPPLIES.
AND EACH STOR--
EACH TOTE HAS A STORY LIKE THAT.
JACK, IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
THANK YOU.
IT REALLY IS,
AND IT'S BEAUTIFULLY MADE.
THANK YOU.
THE QUALITY IS INCREDIBLE.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
WE'VE SOLD $60,000 OF BACKPACKS
IN THE PAST 10 MONTHS,
AND THAT'S FUNDED $6,000
IN MICROLOANS.
HOW IN THE WORLD DID YOUR DAD
LET YOU GO TO UGANDA?
[ LAUGHTER ]
MY DAD IS
IN THE STATE DEPARTMENT,
SO I MOVED AROUND THE WORLD
MY WHOLE LIFE.
YOU SAY THAT THESE
ARE DIFFERENT TERRITORIES.
ARE YOU ACTUALLY MAKING THEM
IN THE TERRITORY,
OR THE FABRIC IS JUST
INSPIRED BY IT?
SO, WE GET TRADITIONAL FABRICS
FROM THE COUNTRIES.
ALL OF THE FABRICS COME
TO WHERE THEY'RE MADE,
OUTSIDE OF RICHMOND, VIRGINIA,
AND THEY'RE ASSEMBLED THERE.
AND WHY DON'T YOU MAKE THEM
IN THOSE COUNTRIES?
BECAUSE THAT ALSO
HELPS PROVIDE JOBS.
WE ACTUALLY
DID CONSIDER THAT,
BUT WE'RE REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT PROVIDING
SOME LOCAL BENEFITS HERE
IN THE U.S., AS WELL.
THE FACILITY THAT MAKES THEM
HIRES ADULTS
WITH DISABILITIES
TO HELP
DO THE ASSEMBLY, SO...
OKAY.
WOW.
Greiner:
I THINK THAT'S GREAT.
JACK, WHAT DO YOU
SELL IT FOR?
$65.
AND WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE IT, ALL-IN?
$27.
John: I WOULD PAY MORE
FOR THIS BAG.
WHY ISN'T IT $100?
WELL, SO,
OUR TARGET MARKET
IS COLLEGE STUDENTS
AND YOUNG ADULTS.
Greiner: I DON'T THINK YOU'RE
WRONG IN YOUR PRICE POINT.
KIDS ARE
ON A BUDGET, RIGHT?
YOU'RE MAKING IT
AFFORDABLE TO MANY,
AS OPPOSED TO JUST A FEW.
Herjavec: WHAT --
WHAT'S THE LARGER STRATEGY?
HOW IS THE BUSINESS
GONNA GET BIGGER?
WELL, SO,
THAT'S WHAT PART OF THE MONEY
IS GONNA BE ALLOCATED FOR.
WE WANT TO EXPAND
OUR CAMPUS AMBASSADOR PROGRAM.
DO YOU HAVE THE AMBASSADOR
PROGRAM IN PLACE TODAY?
WE'VE --
ON A VERY SMALL SCALE, YES.
SO, WE'RE FINDING TWO STUDENTS
ON EACH CAMPUS
TO REPRESENT TAALUMA TOTES
AND SPREAD THE WORD
ON THEIR CAMPUS.
DO THEY GET PAID
FOR THIS ACTIVITY?
THIS ACTUALLY CAME
FROM AN INSANE NUMBER OF E-MAILS
THAT WE GET FROM STUDENTS
JUST ASKING TO BE INVOLVED.
SO, THEY JUST WANT
TO HELP THE CAUSE?
YEAH, THERE'S NO PAYROLL
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
O'Leary: DON'T WORRY --
WHEN YOU GET OLDER,
YOU'LL TURN INTO
A CAPITALIST.
[ LAUGHTER ]
HOW -- HOW ARE YOU DOING
THE MICROLOANS?
I'D LIKE TO CLARIFY THAT.
YEAH, SO, IT IS A LOAN.
IT'S A SMALL LOAN
THAT'S GIVEN TO AN ENTREPRENEUR
IN THE DEVELOPING WORLD
TO GROW THEIR BUSINESS.
RIGHT.
ONCE THEY CAN DO THAT
AND GENERATE THEIR OWN INCOME,
THEY PAY IT BACK
WITHIN 12 MONTHS,
AND WE USE THAT MONEY
TO BUY FABRIC FROM THAT COUNTRY
FOR THE NEXT BACKPACK,
CLOSING THE LOOP.
Herjavec:
JACK, ALLEY, VERY IMPRESSIVE.
YOU KNOW, YOU TOOK AN IDEA,
YOU RAN WITH IT.
I THINK THE PRODUCT
IS JUST BEAUTIFUL.
THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW, WE'RE --
WE'RE HERE TO HELP BUSINESSES
WHERE OUR CAPITAL
AND EXPERTISE
CAN TAKE THEM
TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
I MEAN, AT THIS POINT, REALLY,
THIS INVESTMENT
IS GONNA KICK IT -- KICK-START
US UP TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
I MEAN, THE THINGS THAT ARE
HOLDING US BACK -- INVENTORY.
WE'VE RUN OUT A FEW TIMES
IN THE PAST 10 MONTHS
BECAUSE WE COULDN'T KEEP UP
WITH DEMAND.
RIGHT, BUT THEY
ALREADY HAVE TO BE
AT A CERTAIN LEVEL
TO SPRINGBOARD.
I THINK THAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT THE STRATEGY,
THE PRICE POINT, YOU KNOW,
THE AMBASSADOR PROGRAM.
YOU'RE GONNA FIGURE IT OUT.
I JUST THINK
IT'S A LITTLE EARLY.
I'M OUT.
WE'RE MOVING QUICK.
WE'RE -- I MEAN,
WE'RE FAST LEARNERS AND --
OH, YOU ARE, AND --
AND YOU'RE GOING TO,
AND THAT'S HOW YOU LEARN,
RIGHT?
ABSOLUTELY, YEAH.
YOU'RE -- YOU'RE GONNA TRY,
YOU'RE GONNA FAIL,
YOU'RE GONNA FALL DOWN,
AND YOU'RE GONNA DO WHAT?
PICK --
PICK RIGHT BACK UP.
I MEAN, THAT'S WHAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING FOR 10 MONTHS.
GUYS, WHAT I SEE,
YOU SHOULD BE PROUD --
GREAT PRODUCT, BUT YOU'RE
A PRODUCT, NOT A COMPANY.
LIKE YOU SAID, YOU'VE FALLEN
DOWN, AND YOU'VE GOTTEN BACK UP.
YOU HAVEN'T FALLEN DOWN
ENOUGH YET.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
ALL RIGHT, WELL,
WE THANK YOU, ANYWAY.
THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW, WHEN
I FIRST STARTED MY BUSINESS,
I HAD ONE PRODUCT IDEA,
SAME AS YOU,
AND ONE OF
THE GREATEST THINGS FOR ME WAS
THAT I HAD TO
FIGURE EVERYTHING OUT.
I WAS ALONE.
BUT AS I GREW A BUSINESS,
I THEN KNEW
HOW TO RUN ALL FACETS OF IT,
AND I COULD CONTINUE
TO MAKE MORE AND MORE PRODUCTS.
I THINK YOU HAVE
ALL THESE STEPS AHEAD OF YOU.
THE TWO OF YOU TOGETHER,
IF YOU LEARN THEM,
YOU'RE GONNA BECOME
MUCH STRONGER.
BUT FOR ME, IT'S TOO EARLY.
I'M SORRY. I'M OUT.
ALL RIGHT, WELL,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR FEEDBACK.
THANK YOU
FOR YOUR FEEDBACK.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
John: I HAVE TO TAKE --
MY HAT'S OFF TO YOU
BECAUSE TOO MANY KIDS THESE DAYS
ARE JUST TRYING TO MAKE MONEY
AND DEVELOP AN APP BECAUSE
THAT'S THE NEW GOLD RUSH,
AND YOU'RE ACTUALLY TRYING
TO MAKE CHANGE.
[ CHUCKLES ] THANK YOU.
HERE WAS MY CHALLENGE --
YOU REALLY WEREN'T THINKING
ABOUT THE MARGIN,
AND THAT MEANS
YOU WILL NOT BE ABLE TO SUSTAIN
AT THE CURRENT PRICE.
AND I SAY THIS
TO ONE COMPANY EVERY SEASON --
FIRST YOU HAVE TO MAKE IT,
THEN YOU HAVE TO MASTER IT,
AND THEN YOU CAN MATTER.
I'M OUT.
Herjavec: WELL, THERE'S
ONLY ONE COUNTRY LEFT.
KEVIN?
I HAD A LITTLE CONNECTION
WITH THIS WHEN ALLEY SAID
THAT HER DAD WORKED AT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT AND TRAVELED A LOT.
THAT WAS ALSO MY STORY.
I LIVED IN CAMBODIA, TUNISIA,
ETHIOPIA, CYPRUS, JAPAN,
SWITZERLAND, FRANCE.
WOW.
EVERY TWO YEARS, WE MOVED.
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS,
YOU KNOW,
AND I ALWAYS
GET DRAGGED BACK TO REALITY,
BUT THAT'S WHAT I LOVE
ABOUT MYSELF.
THAT'S WHY THEY CALL ME
"MR. WONDERFUL."
YOU GUYS ARE NOT WORTH
$700,000 -- NOWHERE NEAR IT.
IT'S WAY, WAY, WAY TOO EARLY.
BUT I DON'T THINK YOUR COMPANY'S
EVEN WORTH $110,000 YET.
SO, AS FAR AS
THE VALUATION GOES,
WE'RE VALUING THE COMPANY
ON SOMETHING MORE THAN THAT.
AND WHAT WE'VE LEARNED
FROM THIS --
THESE FIRST FEW MONTHS
WAS HOW TO BUILD A COMMUNITY
AROUND OUR MISSION,
RATHER THAN JUST SELL A PRODUCT
TO A CUSTOMER.
AND THAT IS SO MUCH MORE
VALUABLE
AND SO MUCH MORE GENUINE,
AS YOU --
NO, YOU'RE -- YOU'RE RIGHT.
IT'S --
IT'S BEAUTIFUL TO STRETCH,
BUT WHAT HAPPENS IS
WHEN YOU END UP
IN FRONT OF A FINANCIAL INVESTOR
LIKE ME,
WHO'S GOT TREMENDOUS DISCIPLINE,
'CAUSE HE'S BEEN AROUND
A LONG TIME,
I LOOK FOR THE POTENTIAL
OF FREE CASH FLOW
IN THE NEXT 36 MONTHS.
THAT'S WHEN YOU CAN DETERMINE
WHETHER THIS IS A HOBBY
OR A BUSINESS.
LOOK, YOU'RE
WAY TOO EMBRYONIC FOR ME.
I'M OUT.
ALL RIGHT,
THANK YOU, ANYWAYS.
THANK YOU
FOR YOUR FEEDBACK.
MAYBE WE CHOSE THE WRONG
STRATEGY IN OUR FIRST YEAR.
WE SHOULD HAVE
CHASED THE --
Cuban: NO, NO, NO.
YOU JUST -- YOU --
YOU GO THROUGH THE PROCESS,
AND YOU LEARN.
OKAY.
IT JUST DOESN'T ALL HAPPEN
IN ONE YEAR.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
RIGHT.
IT TAKES TIME.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR THE FEEDBACK.
THANK YOU.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
GOOD LUCK, GUYS.
GOOD LUCK.
Alley: THANKS.
John:
I LOVE ENTREPRENEURS LIKE THIS.
I LOVE THEM.
THEY WANT TO MAKE A CHANGE,
BUT YOU CAN'T MAKE A CHANGE
IF YOU DON'T STAY IN BUSINESS.
I PROBABLY WOULD PAY $200
FOR THIS IF I --
ESPECIALLY WITH THE STORY,
IF YOU KNEW THE STORY.
WITH THE STORY,
I WOULD PAY $200 FOR THIS,
AND I WOULD BE PROUD.
MY NAME IS RYAN FANT.
AND I'M NAYEEM HUSSAIN.
WE'RE FROM NEW YORK CITY.
AND WE'RE THE CO-FOUNDERS
OF KEEN HOME.
TAXI!
RYAN AND I MET STUDYING AT
THE NYU STERN SCHOOL
OF BUSINESS DOING OUR MBAs.
WE BECAME
VERY GOOD FRIENDS.
LOOK AT THIS.
KEEP GOING.
[ BOTH LAUGH ]
OH!
NYU HAS AN AMAZING
ENTREPRENEURSHIP PROGRAM.
WE ENTERED
A BUSINESS COMPETITION CALLED
THE ENTREPRENEURS CHALLENGE.
THEY AWARDED US
AN $18,000 GRANT.
AND THIS YEAR,
WE EARNED A SPOT
IN INC. MAGAZINE'S
"COOLEST COLLEGE STARTUPS."
SO, HEAR, HEAR!
IT REALLY GAVE US
THE CONFIDENCE
THAT THE BUSINESS THAT WE WERE
CREATING REALLY HAD LEGS.
WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT
SOME BOXES.
I LIKE
THE SLEEVE CONCEPT HERE.
WE'VE SINCE GRADUATED
FROM NYU.
NOW RYAN AND I ARE FULL TIME
AT KEEN HOME,
AND WE'RE LOOKING TO BRING
OUR FIRST PRODUCT TO MARKET.
THERE WE GO.
WE NEED AN INVESTMENT
FROM THE SHARKS
TO HELP US SCALE
TO MEET DEMAND
AND GROW THE COMPANY
EVEN FASTER.
I THINK PART OF BEING
AN ENTREPRENEUR
IS REALLY JUST BELIEVING
THAT YOU'RE GONNA SUCCEED
NO MATTER WHAT.
AND WE REALLY BELIEVE
THAT KEEN HOME IS SOMETHING
THAT'S GONNA TAKE US
VERY FAR IN LIFE.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS RYAN FANT.
AND I'M NAYEEM HUSSAIN.
AND WE'RE THE CO-FOUNDERS
OF KEEN HOME,
HEADQUARTERED
IN NEW YORK, NEW YORK.
WE'RE SEEKING $750,000 IN
EXCHANGE FOR 10% OF OUR COMPANY.
Hussain: THE KEEN VENT IS
A WIRELESSLY CONNECTED AIR VENT
THAT AUTOMATICALLY OPENS
AND CLOSES
TO INTELLIGENTLY REDIRECT
AIRFLOW THROUGHOUT A HOME.
THE KEEN VENT
IS EASILY USER-INSTALLED.
A CUSTOMER SIMPLY REMOVES
THE EXISTING VENT
FROM THE DUCT OPENING
AND INSERTS OUR PRODUCT
IN ITS PLACE.
ONCE INSTALLED,
THE VENT AUTOMATICALLY CONNECTS
TO THE INTERNET.
THE AVERAGE U.S. HOUSEHOLD
SPENDS HALF IT'S ENERGY BILL
ON HEATING AND COOLING.
NOW, YOU WOULDN'T USE
A SINGLE LIGHT SWITCH
TO CONTROL ALL THE LIGHTS
IN YOUR HOME,
SO WHY ARE WE STILL RELIANT
ON A CENTRAL THERMOSTAT
FOR THE HEATING-AND-COOLING
NEEDS OF INDIVIDUAL ROOMS?
WITH THE KEEN VENT,
YOU CAN USE YOUR SMARTPHONE
TO TAKE CONTROL
OF YOUR AIRFLOW.
SO, SHARKS, ARE YOU READY
TO HELP US MAKE EVERY HOME...
Both: ...A KEEN HOME?
SO, IT'S A THERMOSTAT,
IN ESSENCE?
NOT REALLY --
IT'S AN AIRFLOW --
SO, IS IT
JUST A AIRFLOW --
THINK ABOUT IT AS A COMPLEMENT
TO AN EXISTING THERMOSTAT.
SO, IF YOU HAVE
A SMART THERMOSTAT, LIKE A NEST,
IT'LL MAKE
YOUR NEST SMARTER.
HOW MUCH MONEY DO I SAVE
IN A MONTH?
IF MY TYPICAL BILL
IS 600 BUCKS...
SURE. YEP.
...HOW MUCH MONEY
DO I SAVE?
THE AVERAGE HOMEOWNER
SPENDS $2,000 PER YEAR
ON HEATING AND COOLING.
IF WE CAN REDUCE THE COST
BY EVEN JUST 10%,
WHICH WOULD BE WAY LESS
THAN WHAT OUR TESTS HAVE SHOWN.
YOU HAVE A TWO-YEAR R.O.I.
IT'S A TWO-YEAR R.O.I.
HOW MANY UNITS DID THEY PUT
IN EACH ONE OF THOSE HOUSES?
FOUR TO UP TO SIX.
FOUR.
WE HAD A --
OUR PRODUCT
COSTS $80 PER VENT.
OKAY, SO, NOT -- NOT --
OKAY, SO --
SO, A SYSTEM OF FOUR
IS $320.
HOW MUCH HAVE YOU ALL INVESTED,
AND HOW MUCH HAVE YOU
GONE OUTSIDE TO GET?
THIS IS ABOUT -- THIS IS
ABOUT TO GET TO INVESTORS
AND ALL KIND OF STUFF
RIGHT NOW.
YEAH, SO,
WE INVESTED $50,000 --
WE INVESTED $50,000
OF OUR PERSONAL MONEY,
AND THEN WE RAISED, RIGHT
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR,
$120,000 AS A PART OF THE
TECHSTARS ACCELERATOR PROGRAM.
UH-HUH.
AND THEN, IN MAY, WE CLOSED
A SEED ROUND OF $1.5 MILLION.
THERE YOU GO.
THAT'S WHAT I WAS LOOKING FOR.
[ LAUGHS ]
SILLY GOOSE.
OH, THE PUNCH LINE,
RIGHT?
YOU DIDN'T THINK
WE WERE GONNA GET TO THAT, HUH?
WHAT WAS THE PRE-MONEY --
WHAT WAS THE PRE-MONEY VALUE
ON THE $1.5 MILLION?
$3.75 MILLION.
MM-HMM.
SO, THAT ROUND PUTS YOU AT A
POST-MONEY OF ABOUT $5 MILLION?
ABOUT --
ROUGHLY $5 MILLION, YEAH.
$5 MILLION, YEAH.
WHAT IS THE ADDED VALUE
THAT MAKES ME PAY
AN ADDITIONAL $2.5 MILLION,
'CAUSE YOU'RE ASKING ME
TO GIVE YOU $7.5 MILLION.
NO, MORE THAN THAT.
WHAT'S HAPPENED SINCE MAY
THAT WOULD MAKE ME PAY
THAT MUCH MORE?
WE DE-RISKED THE BUSINESS
FROM BEING AN IDEA TO NOW IT'S
THE PRODUCT. WE HAVE --
NO, YOU HAVEN'T
SOLD ANY YET.
WE'VE PRESOLD 35,000 UNITS
TO LOWE'S.
Greiner: PRESOLD 35,000 UNITS
OH.
35,000 GOING TO LOWE'S.
OH, YEAH. YEAH.
PUNCH LINE NUMBER TWO.
NOW YOU'RE TALKING DIRTY.
DID THEY ASK FOR EXCLUSIVITY
FOR A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME?
YEAH, SO THERE'S --
HOW LONG?
SO, THERE'S
A TWO-YEAR EXCLUSIVE IN --
WHOA! NO --
IN THE HOME-IMPROVEMENT
CHANNEL --
ONLY IN THE HOME-IMPROVEMENT
CHANNEL.
IN THE HOME IMPROVEMENT --
MM-HMM.
NOW, CAN YOU STILL SELL,
THOUGH, ONLINE?
YEP, MM-HMM.
OH, YES. OH, YES.
AND CAN YOU SELL
TO INDEPENDENTS?
YES.
AND CAN YOU SELL IT
TO OTHER CORPORATIONS, B2B?
YEAH.
100%, YEAH.
ALL RIGHT.
GUYS, WHEN I LOOK AT THIS,
I SAY THIS IS A FEATURE,
NOT A PRODUCT.
OKAY.
RIGHT?
YOU'RE A FEATURE
OF THE AUTOMATED HOME.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT --
WHEN SOMEONE WALKS INTO
THAT LOWE'S STORE,
THEY ARE LOOKING
TO AUTOMATE THEIR HOMES,
NOT AUTOMATE THEIR VENTS.
MM-HMM.
RIGHT?
THAT'S THE CHALLENGE.
I DON'T THINK THAT YOU HAVE
AN AUTOMATED CURE FOR THAT.
YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY.
YOU'RE A LONG WAYS FROM IT.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
Greiner:
HERE'S MY PROBLEM --
I'M A LITTLE CONFUSED ABOUT
WHAT EXACTLY THIS IS GOING TO DO
AND HOW IT'S GOING TO WORK.
I GET THE OVERALL CONCEPT.
MM-HMM.
BUT I STILL DON'T HAVE IT
REALLY CLEAR.
AND TO ME,
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
YOU NEED TO HAVE SOMETHING
REALLY FAST,
WHERE PEOPLE STOP IN THE AISLE,
AND THEY GO,
"I KNOW WHAT THAT IS."
BECAUSE I FIND
THAT IT'S CONFUSING,
AND I THINK
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE DIFFICULTY
EXPLAINING QUICKLY IN THE RETAIL
STORE WHAT IT IS, I'M OUT.
MY ISSUE'S STRICTLY FINANCIAL
WITH YOU GUYS
'CAUSE I PUT UP $750,000 --
I GET 10%, WHICH IS MARGINAL,
WHICH BOTHERS ME AS A SHARK,
I MUST TELL YOU,
BECAUSE I LIKE DEALS.
WELL, WE LEARNED IT
FROM YOU.
NO, I KNOW, BUT, LISTEN,
I'M LOOKING AT IT, SAYING,
"ONLY A FEW MONTHS AGO,
"SOMEBODY ELSE BOUGHT IN
AT UNDER $500,000
OR JUST AROUND $500,000,
AND I'VE GOT TO PAY $750,000."
THAT DOESN'T SIT WELL WITH ME --
I HAVE TO BE HONEST WITH YOU.
WELL, WHAT ARE YOU
GONNA DO?
Fant:
WELL, MAKE AN OFFER.
WELL, I THINK, FOR MY VALUE,
WHICH IS ALWAYS A LOT...
Cuban: WAIT FOR IT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
...OKAY?
WAIT FOR IT.
...I'M THINKING WHAT MAKES SENSE
IS $750,000 FOR 25%.
IT'S A LITTLE RICH.
NOT REALLY.
[ CHUCKLES ]
AND WE HAVE
A FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITY
TO OUR EXISTING SHAREHOLDERS,
OF COURSE.
NO, I UNDERSTAND THAT, BUT
THERE'S ONLY ONE MR. WONDERFUL.
THERE'S VALUE IN THAT.
THANK GOD.
[ LAUGHS ]
I THINK THAT'S
A REASONABLE OFFER, ACTUALLY.
SO, KEVIN'S OFFER
WAS $750,000 FOR 25%.
MM-HMM.
GIVES YOU A VALUE
OF ABOUT $3 MILLION.
MAKES SENSE.
I AGREE WITH KEVIN.
I DON'T THINK
YOU'VE DEMONSTRATED
ENOUGH UPLIFT IN THE VALUE
FROM THE PERIOD OF TIME.
AH.
ALL RIGHT, DAYMOND,
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
$750,000 FOR 25%.
THAT'S MY OFFER.
THAT'S YOUR OFFER. I'M GONNA
MATCH THAT -- $750,000 FOR 25%,
BUT I WOULD LIKE
TO MANUFACTURE THE GOODS
IF I CAN MATCH
OR BEAT THE PRICE
SO THAT I CAN MAKE MONEY
ON THAT SIDE.
INTERESTING.
OKAY.
THAT'S INTERESTING.
I'M LOOKING AT
THE COMMERCIAL APPLICATION.
I'M LOOKING AT TRYING TO GO
AND APPROACH HOTELS --
ALL THOSE AREAS
THAT YOU'RE NOT BLOCKED OUT OF
DUE TO LOWE'S,
ALL RIGHT? SO --
WE'VE BEEN IN DISCUSSIONS
WITH A VERY LARGE HOTEL CHAIN
TO PLACE THESE INTO
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEIR ROOMS
ALL ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
WELL, 'CAUSE THAT'S WHERE
THE EFFICIENCY MATTERS.
MM-HMM. MM-HMM. YEP.
IF YOU HAVE 3,000 OR 2,000
ROOMS, YOU CAN CUT THEM OFF.
YEP.
MM-HMM.
Herjavec:
I THINK YOU'VE DONE A GOOD JOB.
YOU'RE A FEATURE,
BUT THAT'S OKAY.
ONCE CISCO CONTROLLED
THE BIG I.T. MARKET...
SURE, MM-HMM.
...AND THERE'S
LOTS OF LITTLE COMPANIES
THAT CONTROL FEATURES
OF IT.
MM-HMM.
SO, I'M OKAY WITH THAT.
TODAY, IT'S VENTS,
TOMORROW, IT'S THAT.
CORRECT.
I MEAN, I DON'T THINK
YOU REALLY NEED
THE HELP
WITH THE MANUFACTURING.
SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'RE ON TRACK.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
THIS IS WHERE HE TRIES
TO STAB US IN THE BACK.
Narrator: TWO SHARKS ARE OUT.
NAYEEM AND RYAN HAVE
TWO OFFERS ON THE TABLE
FROM DAYMOND AND KEVIN FOR
THEIR SMART AIR VENT, KEEN HOME,
BUT ROBERT IS ALSO INTERESTED.
SO, DAYMOND AND KEVIN
ARE $750,000 FOR 25%.
I THINK THAT'S A LITTLE RICH.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $750,000
FOR 20%.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR OFFER.
THAT'S A GOOD OFFER.
THAT'S STILL A DOWN ROUND.
IT'S STILL A DOWN ROUND.
THAT'S CORRECT.
DOWN ROUNDS SEND ALL KINDS OF
SIGNALS IN THE MARKETPLACE,
AS YOU ALL WELL KNOW,
AND THAT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE LOOKING
TO ENTERTAIN RIGHT NOW.
OKAY, I'LL SOLVE
YOUR PROBLEM FOR YOU.
LET'S GO DEBT, ALL RIGHT?
YOU'LL GIVE ME THE 10%,
I'LL GIVE YOU VENTURE DEBT.
I'LL GIVE YOU $750,000
AT 8.5%, OKAY?
MM-HMM.
AND I WANT 10% EQUITY
FOR THAT.
MM-HMM.
I'LL PUT THE MONEY UP
FOR 36 MONTHS, ALL RIGHT?
OKAY.
BUT IT SOLVES YOUR DOWN-ROUND
PROBLEM, AND YOU GET A SHARK.
I WOULD BE WILLING TO GO IN
WITH KEVIN ON HIS DEAL.
YOU WANT
TO GO 50-50?
WHERE YOU'RE AT, VENTURE DEBT
IS NOT A BAD OPTION FOR YOU.
SURE.
IF LORI COMES IN WITH ME,
YOU GET TWO SHARKS,
AND YOU DO NOT DO A DOWN ROUND.
RIGHT, BUT I WANT 25%.
A DOWN ROUND, MAN.
NO, HOLD ON.
THEY CALL HIM
"MR. DOWN ROUND."
I CAN -- I CAN CARVE IT
A DIFFERENT WAY.
DAYMOND, THEY'RE NOT GONNA DO
THE DOWN ROUND.
ARE YOU PARTNERS
WITH THEM ALREADY?
I THINK THE LOAN OFFER
IS INTERESTING.
I GET WHY YOU DON'T WANT TO DO
A DOWN ROUND.
I RESPECT THAT.
WHAT I'M REALLY FASCINATED BY
IS THE COMPLIANCE
THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN
IN THIS INDUSTRY.
IT'S GONNA BE DRIVEN
BY THE INSURANCE COMPANIES
FOR SMARTER HOMES.
YEP. MM-HMM. MM-HMM.
AND I THINK THAT'S GONNA TAKE
ALL OF THIS TO ANOTHER LEVEL.
WE AGREE.
MM-HMM.
$750,000 FOR 13% --
THAT'S MY OFFER.
OKAY.
O'Leary: THAT DEAL'S GONNA
COST YOU MORE EQUITY.
I HAVE A LOT OF PRODUCTS
THAT ARE FITTING
IN THE HARDWARE SPACE.
WE'RE IN LOWE'S, WE'RE IN
HOME DEPOT, BED BATH & BEYOND.
THERE'S A LOT OF PLACES
YOU CAN GO.
AGREED.
MM-HMM.
UM, I'LL --
I'M WILLING TO GO DOWN MORE
TO, UH, $750,000 FOR 20%.
YOU DON'T HAVE
PROOF OF CONCEPT YET.
YOU HAVE A GREAT START
BECAUSE OF THE LOWE'S --
DOESN'T MEAN
LOWE'S IS GONNA SELL IT,
DOESN'T MEAN IT'S GONNA WORK
OVER THERE.
IT'S A LITTLE EARLY.
I NEVER LIKE TO TAKE DEBT
WHEN I'M AT THIS STAGE.
I'M AN ALL-IN KIND OF GUY
WHEN YOU'RE THIS SMALL.
WHEN YOU GET BIGGER,
SURE, TAKE ON DEBT,
BUT WHEN YOU'RE SMALL,
YOU GOT TO DRIVE IT, BABY.
YOU GOT TO GO.
BUT YOU'LL HAVE
SO MANY SALES,
AND YOU'LL HAVE SO MUCH MONEY,
IT WON'T MATTER.
THOSE ARE THE OFFERS.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
WE'RE LOOKING FOR,
AT THIS STAGE OF OUR COMPANY,
A REAL PARTNER WHO'S GONNA
JUMP ALL-IN AND --
AND TAKE THIS WILD
RIDE WITH US.
OH, THANKS.
OH, HE'S TALKING ABOUT ME.
I THINK
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT ME.
SO -- SO WE'D -- WE'D LOVE
TO ACCEPT YOUR OFFER, ROBERT.
WAIT. WHAT IS THAT?
Greiner: GOOD DEAL.
AH.
CONGRATS, ROBERT.
I LOVE IT. THANK YOU.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
WELCOME TO THE KEEN --
FOR SURE.
YEAH, GREAT JOB, GUYS.
THANK YOU.
Greiner: CONGRATS, GUYS.
GOOD LUCK.
THANK YOU.
THANKS.
THANKS, GUYS.
BYE.
Herjavec:
YEAH. THANK YOU.
MAN, WHATEVER, ROBERT.
[ BOTH LAUGH ]
Hussain: ROBERT REALLY SEEMED
TO UNDERSTAND THE BRAND VISION.
HE HAS THE ABILITY TO
BUILD BRANDS, BUILD COMPANIES,
AND REALLY, MOST IMPORTANTLY,
BUILD STRATEGIC PARTNERSHIPS.
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A PRODUCT DESIGNED
TO HELP STUDENTS WITH
THE HIGH COST OF COLLEGE.
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS CHRISTOPHER GRAY,
I'M FROM PHILADELPHIA,
PENNSYLVANIA,
AND MY COMPANY IS SCHOLLY.
I'M SEEKING $40,000
FOR 15% OF MY COMPANY.
COLLEGE IS EXPENSIVE.
I KNOW -- I'M A STUDENT.
THE COST OF COLLEGE
RISES EVERY YEAR,
AND STUDENTS AND PARENTS
ARE FORCED
TO TAKE OUT STUDENT LOANS
TO PAY THE BILLS.
THIS PUTS MANY STUDENTS
IN INSURMOUNTABLE DEBT.
BUT THERE'S AN ALTERATIVE --
SCHOLARSHIPS.
THE ONLY PROBLEM IS
THESE SCHOLARSHIPS
ARE EXTREMELY HARD TO FIND.
THIS CAUSES MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN FREE MONEY TO GO TO WASTE,
AS MANY STUDENTS DON'T KNOW
THIS MONEY EXISTS.
SO, THAT'S WHY
I CREATED SCHOLLY.
SCHOLLY'S A MOBILE APP
THAT MATCHES STUDENTS
WITH HUNDREDS
OF POTENTIAL SCHOLARSHIPS.
YOU SIMPLY INPUT SOME
INFORMATION ABOUT YOURSELF,
SUCH AS THE STATE YOU LIVE IN,
YOUR GPA, AND PRESS "MATCH"...
AND THERE YOU HAVE IT --
A LIST OF SCHOLARSHIPS
YOU QUALIFY FOR,
LITERALLY IN MINUTES.
SO, WE HAVE, LIKE,
THE LORI SCHOLARSHIP,
BANK OF THE TANK,
SHARK BAIT SCHOLARSHIP,
MR. WONDERFUL'S
STINGY SCHOLARSHIP.
SEE? $1,000.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Cuban:
I LIKE HIM ALREADY.
WE LOVE YOU ALREADY.
BOY, YOU'RE REALLY
SUCKING UP TO ME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
YOU'RE STINGY, MAN.
I CAN'T -- WHAT CAN I SAY?
SCHOLLY ISN'T JUST A BUSINESS,
IT'S MY PASSION.
I WANT TO HELP STUDENTS
LIKE MYSELF
FIND MONEY TO GO TO
THE COLLEGE OF THEIR DREAMS.
SO, INVESTING IN SCHOLLY
MEANS THAT YOU, TOO,
CAN MAKE SOME DREAMS
COME TRUE.
SO LET'S DO THIS.
CHRISTOPHER, GREAT IDEA.
YOU ARE 100% CORRECT.
THERE ARE SO MANY SCHOLARSHIPS,
IT'S A JUNGLE.
YES.
I DON'T KNOW HOW PEOPLE
FIGURE IT ALL OUT.
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS --
IS THAT THE ACTUAL APP
THAT YOU SHOWED ME?
THAT'S THE ACTUAL APP.
THE APP IS FOR iPhone
AND ANDROID, YES.
HOW ARE YOU CURATING
ALL THE SCHOLARSHIPS?
I'VE ACTUALLY BEEN BUILDING
DATABASES AND HELPING STUDENTS
WITH SCHOLARSHIPS
FOR A COUPLE YEARS NOW.
AND I AGGREGATED
THAT LIST OF SCHOLARSHIPS
FROM DIFFERENT WEBSITES,
THEN I MANUALLY INPUT THEM,
AND, BASICALLY,
ONCE THEY'RE IN OUR DATABASE,
WE DON'T -- WE DON'T HAVE TO
MANAGE THE PROCESS ANYMORE.
DO YOU DO THIS BY YOURSELF,
OR DO YOU HAVE PARTNERS?
I HAVE TWO CO-FOUNDERS.
THEY BOTH ARE APP
AND WEB DEVELOPERS.
I AM THE --
I'M THE BUSINESS GUY, THE C.E.O.
HOW'D YOU COME UP
WITH THIS IDEA?
SO, I'M JUST RIGHT
NOW A JUNIOR.
I'M AN UNDERGRADUATE
AT DREXEL UNIVERSITY.
I WON $1.3 MILLION
IN SCHOLARSHIPS.
$1.3 MILLION?
Cuban: WHAT?!
YES.
O'Leary: REALLY?
I'M FASCINATED BY THAT.
HOW DID YOU ACHIEVE THAT?
YEAH, I MEAN,
THAT'S LIKE A LOTTERY WIN.
SO -- YES, SO --
HOW DID YOU GET THERE?
YEAH, SO, I --
IT TOOK ME A WHILE.
IT TOOK ME ABOUT SEVEN MONTHS
BEGINNING IN MY JUNIOR YEAR
TO REALLY FIND ALL
THESE DIFFERENT SCHOLARSHIPS.
I SCOURED THE WEB.
I GOT MULTIPLE
FULL-RIDE SCHOLARSHIPS.
I GOT COCA--
THE COCA-COLA SCHOLARSHIP.
WHAT WAS
THE BIGGEST ONE?
THE BILL GATES SCHOLARSHIP.
HOW MUCH?
WOW.
IT'S A FULL RIDE TO ANY COLLEGE
YOU WANT TO GO TO.
TELL ME MORE ABOUT YOUR DRIVE
TO GET THE SCHOLARSHIPS.
I HAD A SINGLE MOM --
LOW INCOME, TWO SIBLINGS.
AND I HAD TO WORK
REALLY HARD.
I HAD A GREAT GPA,
I HAD GREAT TEST SCORES,
AND I ACTUALLY COULD NOT APPLY
TO SOME OF THE SCHOOLS
I WANTED TO GO TO
BECAUSE OF THE APPLICATION FEES.
I THINK WE CAN ALL RELATE
TO THAT STORY.
RIGHT.
I'M THE FIRST PERSON
IN MY ENTIRE FAMILY
EVER TO GO TO COLLEGE.
I GET THE VALUE.
WHAT YOU JUST DID
WAS AMAZING.
SO, DO YOU THINK, LIKE,
YOU COULD GET ME $1.3 MILLION...
YES.
...FOR EDUCATING THESE --
THESE BOBOS UP HERE
FOR THE LAST FIVE YEARS?
YEAH, SO --
SO, ACTUALLY, WITH SCHOLLY,
EVERY STUDENT THAT USES OUR APP
IS MATCHED BETWEEN 120
TO 220 SCHOLARSHIPS,
TOTALING OVER $4 MILLION.
SO IT'S GIVING THEM ACCESS
TO WIN ALL THAT MONEY.
SO, IN OTHER WORDS, YOU --
YOU FOUND THE ONES THAT ARE --
ARE -- ARE
INSTITUTIONAL-NEUTRAL.
OUT--
THEY DON'T CARE
WHERE YOU GO.
YES, SCHOLLY FOCUSES
ON OUTSIDE SCHOLARSHIPS.
WE'RE NOT -- WE'RE NOT BOOKED
ON INSTITUTIONAL SCHOLARSHIPS.
SO, TO DAYMOND...
Herjavec: AH.
...SO, DAYMOND,
YOUR QUESTION IS --
THERE ARE ABOUT $100 MILLION
THAT GOES UNCLAIMED
IN OUTSIDE SCHOLARSHIPS,
MAINLY 'CAUSE STUDENTS
DON'T KNOW THEY EXIST.
OKAY, CHRISTOPHER,
HOW DO I MAKE MONEY WITH THIS?
SCHO-- SO, SCHOLLY IS 99 CENTS
IN THE APP STORE.
WE ALREADY SOLD 92,000 APPS.
HOW MANY?
92,000 PAID APPS,
LESS THAN A YEAR,
AND ALL
WITH ZERO MARKETING.
SO, IT'S REALLY COOL.
WE HAD A VERY EFFECTIVE
P.R. STRATEGY GOING FOR IT.
SO, I USED THE FACT THAT I WON
$1.3 MILLION IN SCHOLARSHIPS
AND PITCHED REPORTERS
TO THE FACT
THAT I CREATED THIS APP
FOR OTHER PEOPLE.
IT'S BRILLIANT.
Greiner: DO YOU WANT
TO KNOW SOMETHING, CHRISTOPHER?
GO AHEAD.
I'M GONNA DO SOMETHING
I'VE NEVER DONE BEFORE.
I HAVEN'T HEARD
A WHOLE LOT,
BUT I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
AN OFFER RIGHT NOW.
AWESOME.
Cuban: LET ME JUST ASK
SOME REAL QUESTIONS, OKAY?
MY OFFER RIGHT NOW IS
THE 40K FOR 15%.
I BELIEVE IN YOU.
I BELIEVE IN WHAT
YOU'RE DOING -- IS GOOD.
I THINK THAT WE WILL
MAKE IT TOGETHER.
SO I HOPE
YOU JUST SAY YES.
I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR
OTHER OFFERS, LORI.
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT.
THAT -- THAT REALLY MEANS
A LOT TO ME.
SCHOLLY IS VERY IMPORTANT TO ME.
I'M OFFERING YOU
EXACTLY WHAT YOU ASKED FOR.
YES, I WOULD LOVE TO HE--
I DON'T --
I'M NOT EVEN GONNA ASK YOU,
"HOW DO WE MONETIZE THIS?"
BUT I WANT YOU
TO SAY YES.
John:
I WANT TO BE PART OF THIS.
IT'S REALLY
A PERSONAL MATTER.
I STARTED WORKING
AT 10 YEARS OLD.
AND I WAS RAISED
BY A SINGLE MOTHER.
ME, TOO.
WHEN I GOT TO
ABOUT THE AGE OF 17 YEARS OLD,
I WANTED TO GO TO COLLEGE,
BUT I HAD TO WORK
BECAUSE I SAW
HER WORKING THREE JOBS,
AND THERE WAS
NO FOOD ON THE TABLE.
I RESONATE WITH THIS, SO
I'LL OFFER YOU THE SAME THING --
THE $40,000 FOR 15%.
CHRISTOPHER, LOOK AT ME.
I BELIEVE IN
WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
I-I-I--
I DON'T CARE ABOUT HOW
WE'RE GOING TO MONETIZE IT.
I JUST WANT YOU
TO TAKE MY HAND
AND SAY "DEAL,"
AND WE WILL MAKE IT WORK.
BUT I'D LIKE YOU TO DO IT
RIGHT NOW.
WOW, THAT'S
PRETTY AGGRESSIVE.
John:
IF SHE HAD THE BEST INTERESTS,
I THINK SHE WOULD LET YOU
LISTEN TO EVERYBODY.
I MEAN IT.
NEVER HAPPENED,
CHRISTOPHER.
I -- WHATEVER WAY,
I WANT TO BE PART OF THIS.
LOOK AT ME.
I-I JUST WANT TO HEAR
WHAT EVERYONE HAS TO SAY.
Herjavec: CHRISTOPHER.
LIKE, I-I LOVE YOUR OFFER.
I LOVE THE MONEY.
DON'T GET IMPATIENT WITH ME,
AND, ALSO --
SO, CHRISTOPHER.
YEAH?
SO, THE KEY TO YOUR SITE
IS YOUR ABILITY
TO UPDATE THE SCHOLARSHIPS.
IS THERE A BACK-END ENGINE
THAT'S TAKING IT ALL IN?
HOW ARE YOU DOING THAT?
HOW MANY DIFFERENT SCHOLARSHIPS
DID YOU SAY
WERE IN YOUR DATABASE?
BETWEEN 10,000 AND 20,000.
OH!
MY CO-FOUNDER
DEVELOPED AN ALGORITHM
WHERE HE GATHERED ALL THE
SCHOLARSHIPS FROM DIFFERENT --
FROM DIFFERENT --
FROM DIFFERENT WEBSITES.
NOW, SEE, THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO GET TO.
YEAH.
LOOK, YOU HAVE
TWO CO-FOUNDERS.
RIGHT.
THEY'RE DEVELOPERS.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT
THEIR SKILL SET IS BECAUSE --
ME -- ME TOO, BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT I NEED TO UNDERSTAND
IS HOW YOU'RE GONNA
CONSTANTLY DO IT.
YOU WALKED IN HERE
WITH A THOUGHT.
THIS COULD BE
A VERY LARGE BUSINESS.
AND DAYMOND AND I BOTH
ARE NOT EVEN ASKING YOU.
[ SIGHS ]
WELL, LET HIM ANSWER IT.
LET HIM ANSWER.
I WANT TO KNOW
WHAT HE SAYS TO THAT.
John: YEAH.
Greiner:
WE'RE SAYING -- YOU KNOW WHAT?
YEAH, BUT THAT'S
EXACTLY THE WRONG THING.
HANG ON. HANG ON.
THAT'S -- THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT HE DOESN'T WANT.
Herjavec:
LORI, YOU'RE MINIMIZING HIM.
JUST HANG ON.
I'M NOT MINIMIZING HIM.
DO YOU WANT
A CHARITY DONATION...
HE ARE READY -- NO.
...OR DO YOU WANT TO BUILD
A BUSINESS? WHICH IS IT?
THAT'S RIDICULOUS.
I MEAN, I -- MY GOAL HERE --
I WANT SOMEONE THAT REALLY
BELIEVES IN WHAT WE'RE DOING.
THIS DOESN'T MEAN -- YEAH.
I TOLD YOU I DID.
John: I BELIEVE IN IT.
ROBERT AND MARK PROBABLY HAVE --
HOW COULD YOU BELIEVE IN IT
WHEN YOU HAVEN'T EVEN ASKED
ABOUT THE ENTIRE BUSINESS
AND HOW IT WORKS?
HERE -- BECAUSE THIS --
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE'LL FIGURE IT OUT.
BECAUSE -- THAT'S RIGHT.
WE'LL TAKE AFFORDABLE
NEXT STEPS FORWARD.
YOU KNOW, CHRISTOPHER,
YOU KNOW --
WE WILL CALL THE OTHER ROBERTS
AND CUBANS OF THE WORLD
TO GIVE US ADVICE ON THIS.
WELL, YOU --
YOU KNOW -- YOU KNOW WHAT? YOU
KNOW WHAT? YOU KNOW WHAT? YEAH.
YOU KNOW WHAT? I'M WILLING
TO DO IT WITH DAYMOND.
YEAH, OKAY.
DAYMOND, IF YOU'RE WILLING
TO DO IT WITH ME...
I ABSOLUTELY WILL DO IT
WITH YOU.
I THINK THAT YOU SHOULD JUST SAY
RIGHT NOW, "DO IT."
OKAY, LORI AND I ARE GONNA GO
IN 50-50 PARTNERS.
THAT'S $20,000 FROM HER,
$20,000 FROM ME
FOR 15% OF YOUR COMPANY.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE
A DECISION NOW.
I'M GONNA TAKE --
I'M GONNA TAKE YOUR DEAL.
DONE.
GOOD. DONE.
THANKS.
ALL RIGHT.
THANKS. THANKS.
THANK, MAN.
THAT'S AWESOME.
THANK YOU.
I LOVE YOU GUYS.
I'M REALLY GLAD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LET'S GET A GROUP HUG.
GROUP HUG.
GROUP -- GROUP HUG!
THANKS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD.
YOU'RE AMAZING.
THANKS.
THANKS SO MUCH.
I AM FEELING REALLY GREAT.
I STEPPED IN THE SHARK TANK
THINKING, LIKE,
"PROFIT, PROFIT, PROFIT,"
BUT I'M REALLY HAPPY TO FIND
TWO SHARKS WHO DON'T --
WHO CARE MORE
ABOUT WHAT SCHOLLY'S GONNA DO
FOR THE PUBLIC THAN --
THAN THE BOTTOM LINE,
SO I'M REALLY HAPPY.
I'M SUPER EXCITED.
YOU KNOW,
WHEN I HAD NOTHING
AND, UH, COULDN'T RUB
TWO PENNIES TOGETHER,
YOU KNOW
WHAT I REALLY HATED?
I HATED WHEN PEOPLE WANTED
TO GIVE ME A BREAK
BECAUSE
THEY FELT BAD FOR ME.
UH, WE'RE NOT DOING IT
BECAUSE WE FEEL BAD FOR HIM.
John: I DIDN'T FEEL BAD.
I DON'T FEEL BAD AT ALL.
Cuban: I NEVER GOT
ONE OF THOSE. [ LAUGHS ]
ARE YOU KIDDING?
I DON'T FEEL BAD AT ALL.
I'M NOT UNDERMINING
WHAT YOU DID.
YEAH, BUT WHY DO YOU THINK
THIS WAS A PITY MOVE?
THE GUY WAS A GREAT GUY.
IT WASN'T A PITY MOVE.
YOU DON'T KNOW HOW
THE BACK-END ENGINE WORKED.
YOU DIDN'T
EVEN KNOW THAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
NO, BUT -- BUT HERE'S WHAT --
HERE'S WHAT I DO KNOW --
HE WAS 99 CENTS AN APP.
BUT I ASKED, "IS IT A CHARITY,
OR IS IT A BUSINESS?"
HE WAS 99 CENTS AN APP.
HE DOWNLOADED 92,000.
Greiner: SOMETIMES,
IT IS NOT ALL ABOUT MONEY.
I'M -- I'M A VERY
CHARITABLE GUY, TOO.
SOMETIMES,
IT'S ABOUT HELPING AMERICA
AND MAKING THE WORLD
A BETTER PLACE.
IS IT A CHARITY?
LORI, THAT IS SUCH CRAP.
NO, IT IS NOT CRAP.
I TELLING YOU --
I'M NOT SITTING HERE --
WE ARE NOT
THE CHARITY TANK.
NO, WE ARE NOT
WE'RE NOT HERE
TO GIVE IT OUT.
THAT'S NOT CHARITY,
ROBERT.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
THAT'S NOT CHARITY, AND --
REALLY?
HOW DOES THAT WORK?
HOW ARE YOU GONNA GROW
THAT BUSINESS?
WHAT'S THE EXECUTION PLAN?
DO YOU KNOW
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO?
WE'RE GONNA BUILD THE
BUSINESS -- TRUST ME ON THIS.
WE'RE GONNA GROW --
PEOPLE GETTING EDUCATIONS.
WHAT? "WE'RE GONNA
FIGURE IT OUT?"
YES, WE'RE GONNA
FIGURE IT OUT.
THAT'S RIGHT.
AMERICA, COME TO THE TANK!
WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU MONEY
BECAUSE WE LIKE YOU.
OH, MY GOD.
OH, YOU DIDN'T INVEST IN ANYBODY
ELSE WHO'S GONNA FIGURE IT OUT.
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
YOU BET ON THE PERSON.
I NEVER GOT ANY INFORMATION.
WITH THE --
WITH THE INFORMATION --
I GOT INFORMATION.
HE WASN'T ALLOWED TO TALK
BECAUSE YOU HAD TO FORCE $40,000
DOWN HIS THROAT
LIKE A GOOSE FOR PT.
[ Laughing ] OH, MY GOD.
YEAH.
NO PROBLEM, GUYS.
THAT'S WHAT HE CAME IN ASKING!
I THOUGHT, AT THAT POINT, THAT
I RECEIVED ENOUGH INFORMATION
TO FEEL LIKE I WANT TO BE PART
OF THE RIDE.
YOU KNOW WHAT, DAYMOND?
IF HE WOULD HAVE JUST SAID,
"THIS IS AN IDEA,"
I WOULDN'T HAVE DONE THAT.
LOOK, I-I'M NOT TRYING
TO GIVE YOU A HARD TIME.
I AGREE.
I'M NOT TRYING TO GIVE YOU A
HARD TIME. YOU KNOW I REALLY --
YOU GUYS JUST DON'T LIKE
WHEN YOU GET SCOOPED.
[ Laughing ] OH!
OH!
THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THAT THIS GUY -- THIS GUY --
IT -- THAT WAS SO --
WAIT. EXCUSE ME.
I'M TALKING.
I ACTUALLY BELIEVE
THAT DAYMOND AND I,
NO MATTER WHAT IT IS
THAT THIS GUY NEEDS --
WE'LL BE THERE TO BACK HIM.
YEAH, BECAUSE YOU JUST
BENT OVER BACKWARDS FOR $40,000.
IT IS NOT
THE CHARITY TANK.
COME ON. COME ON, LORI.
THAT'S RIDICULOUS.
IF YOU'RE TRULY TRYING
TO HELP THE GUY THEN --
I AM.
WAIT. IF YOU'RE TRULY TRYING
TO HELP THE GUY,
WHAT I WANT TO DO
IS ASK HIM QUESTIONS.
THIS IS ALL SOUR GRAPES.
HE STARTED TALKING ABOUT
AN ALGORITHM.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW
ABOUT ALGORITHMS?
IT'S ALL SOUR GRAPES.
IT'S NOT SOUR GRAPES!
YOU KNOW WHAT? YOU'RE
REALLY PISSING ME OFF RIGHT NOW.
I'M GONNA SAY
SOMETHING RUDE TO YOU.
[ LAUGHS ] NO, DON'T,
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT A RUDE GUY.
AND I DON'T WANT TO SAY
SOMETHING RUDE TO YOU,
SO I'M JUST GONNA GO,
OKAY?
BECAUSE I -- THERE WAS NO NEED
TO DO SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
YES, YOU SHOULD DO THAT,
BUT THAT'S ACTUALLY NOT YOU.
YOU GOT --
YOU'RE SMARTER THAN THAT.
YOU'RE NOT THE GUY
TO WALK AWAY AND WALK OFF.
YES, WE'RE THE SHARK TANK,
WE'RE NOT THE CHARITY TANK.
BUT SOMETIMES, THERE'S
A POINT TO BEING COMPASSIONATE
AND CARING ABOUT THINGS
THAT MATTER.
I DON'T THINK
IT'S NOT AN INFLUENCE.
THEN GIVE HIM $100,000.
RUN OUT THERE
AND CHANGE IT TO $100,000.
THINGS THAT MATTER.
BE COMPASSIONATE.
EDUCATION AND SCHOLARSHIP
IS IMPORTANT.
BE COMPASSIONATE.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO THAT.
THE GUY --
HE ALREADY DIED 'CAUSE YOU'VE
CHOKED HIM ON THE $40,000.
OH, MY GOD.
YOU WANT
TO HELP ALL THESE KIDS
AND SEND A MESSAGE,
BE COMPASSIONATE.
YOU KNOW WHAT? I FEEL
REALLY GOOD ABOUT WHAT I DID.
LET'S GO.
DAYMOND, DO YOU?
I FEEL GREAT.
WE FEEL GREAT.
I THINK THEY DON'T LIKE
THAT WE JUMPED IN.
I'M SORRY
THAT THEY WERE UPSET.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
IT'S SOUR GRAPES.
WHAT WE DID WAS GREAT.
THANK YOU.
I LOVE IT.